[Applause]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
recapture enterprise can keep fraudulent
actors away from your online business
each year billions of logins are
attempted with stolen credentials by
creating synthetic accounts or taking
over real accounts hackers can post
false comments or commit fraudulent
transactions on your site
recapture enterprise learns by
monitoring real traffic on your site
recaptcha enterprise uses machine
learning to assign a score to each
request based on how likely it is
legitimate
you can use the score and choose to take
action on the request or let you through
for example you can enforce two-factor
authentication for such requests at the
login page
if the user successfully authenticates
you can then annotate the request as
legitimate
this will improve recaptcha's future
predictions for your site however if you
receive a credit card charge back you
can annotate the request as fraudulent
in addition to the score recaptcha
enterprise returns reason codes that can
help you take the right action
for example if the reason indicates an
automated bot you might throttle the
request or send posts to the moderators
recapture enterprise works with
back-ends running on third-party clouds
on-premises and google cloud
it also supports mobile as well as web
applications
so next time you're looking to keep
fraudulent bots away from your online
business without extra friction
take a minute to explore recapture
enterprise
to learn more check out
cloud.google.com recaptcha enterprise
[Music]